Finns det några grejer ni ofta upptäcker och bara tänker, har ni inte rätt eller har ni inte tänkt berätta?
Jag vet inte vad Joel, jag ska vara helt ärlig med dig.
Jag blir nästan mörkare.
Men jag kan komma in på ett, en av Sveriges största e-medelsbolag och säga att de inte har koll på någonting.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Man är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt den under 60 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kollegor, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Pelle Pettersson till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tjena Pelle.
Tack så hemskt mycket.
Tjena, tjena.
Otroligt skoj att vara här tycker jag.
Ja, jag fick ju, jag tror jag har fått typ fem meddelanden om, kan du inte ta med Pelle i podden?
Och jag har ju privat inte så stor koll på dig.
Vi har ju inte korsat väg tidigare och men, jag tror att omvärlden känner till dig mer än vad jag känner till.
Men kan du inte berätta för mig vem du är?
Thank you, det var roligt att höra Joel för det första.
Det värmer verkligen att du har fått ett meddelande.
Andra delar, innan vi börjar ska jag bara vilja säga grattis till den här vinsten som du plockade hem.
Jag har ju faktiskt hållit lite koll på dig senast i tiden och fantastiskt bra jobbat och väl förtjän, måste jag säga.
Tack så mycket.
Allright, jag då, Pelle heter jag som du nämnde.
Jag är väl, ska vi förenkla att säga det, e-handelskill från grunden.
Startade min första e-handelsbolag när jag var 16.
Och sen hållt på med den digitala sfären.
Sedan dess egentligen i massa olika konstellationer.
Suttit som ansvarig för olika digitala resor i retail och sedan fyra eller fem år tillbaka ungefär grundade jag Onyarch som idag är min huvudsakliga sysslakt.
Vad var den här första e-handeln du grundade?
Var det den här klockkungarna?
Nej men det var bland dem.
Ännu längre bakåt.
Ja precis, klockkungarna var en av de tidiga.
Men innan klockkungarna så hade jag ett bolag som hette Styling Cars.
Det handlade om att sälja stylingdelar till bilar på nätet.
Det var egentligen innan det gick att handla på nätet eller innan i alla fall alla förstod att man kunde handla sådana här delar på nätet.
Så jag byggde upp ett lag hemma hos mig och pappas garage.
Lagom populärt, men väldigt framgångsrikt tänkte jag säga.
Det var kanske inte, men det var väldigt roligt att lära orit om inte annat.
Och jag lärde mig sjukt mycket på hur man bygger affärer, hur man bygger företag och allting sånt redan då.
Så det var en jättevärdefull grund inför min framtida karriär.
Men du drev eget ett tag men sen blev du ändå in i det corporate ladder litegrann.
Vad var det som gjorde att du lämnade egen värden och gick in i...
För du var inne i Servera för mig och det var något mer stort bolag vill jag minnas.
Ja men exakt, exakt.
Så vi drev Klockkungarna under några år som var ett av mina första engangspolag.
Det gick väldigt bra men det var också väldigt väldigt slitsamt.
Vi gick ju utan rikskapital någonting bara för att få ner en kassa.
Och efter en stund, efter några år tillsammans på Klockkungarna så kände jag att nu är det nog dags att ta ett litet break i entreprenörsdelen.
Och framförallt i den kontext att jag ville lära mig att vara på större bolag.
Hur skalar man?
Vad krävs för att vara på ett stort bolag?
Hur fungerar deras handel?
Vad är skillnaden mot att driva en entreprenörslåda, en mindre e-handel egentligen mot att driva en flera hundra miljoner skerhandel?
Och då började min resa som anställd i något år.
Och där ibland hann jag beta av både Uropen som var första, därefter vidare till Severa och sen en kort sväng in på Bonnier och ansvara för lite digital affärsutveckling på Bonnier News.
Så jag har med några olika spår där och det som var gemensamt för alla dem var att det var väldigt lärorikt att få de här stora kontexterna.
Och det är någonting som jag tog med mig sen till framtida karriären, nästa stenkarriär.
Var det så att du tänkte att du jobbade på ett vanligt jobb, jag vet inte vad jag ska kalla det, men du vet, sammanställd.
Tänkte du att du skulle göra det för att sen gå tillbaka och bli egen igen, eller var det för att du mer fascinerades av storleken och ville in i det?
Nej, det var nog...
Jag som person är nog väldigt entreprenör.
Jag tror att jag kan vara anställd, men då måste det vara i en entreprenörsvärld eller en entreprenörsbolag där jag får vara en stark entreprenör.
Men det framför allt syfte var, jag tror att jag alltid haft en tes om att det är ett skoj att driva egna bolag och det är kul att vara entreprenör.
Det jag byggde under de här åren i karriären, det var en utöjkad kunskap och det var sådana här typer av bolag behöver och hur man kan jobba i de bolagen.
Det lade också grunden till nästa entreprenörsresa som blev Omniarch.
Det är relativt ovanligt kanske inte, men man brukar inte gå från eget till anställd, utan man brukar gå tvärtom lite grann.
Men du sa att det var lite jobbigt att vara egen och sen hade latt det vara tungt och slitigt, vilket det är.
Vad var det du saknade när du hade jobbat som anställd några år?
Det är två delar.
En del är att som entreprenör så gillar man ju när saker går snabbt.
I större bolag går inte saker snabbt.
Så är det bara.
Man får inte till det.
I en digital sver så måste man vara snabb.
Så för mig var det givet att jag vill ha en miljö både som jag kan påverka själv hela vägen, oavsett beslut så vill jag vara den här.
Och jag vill ha en miljö där jag kan styra mycket mig själv.
Jag behöver inte jobba med personalpolitik, jag behöver inte jobba med sådana delar.
Det är väldigt viktigt för mig.
Och då kan jag göra saker som jag tycker är roligt.
Och det är ju faktiskt att driva bolag, att bygga framfart, att växa bolag och den delen och utan att hela tiden behöva fråga eller anpassa mig mot eventuell personalpolitik.
Och det blev, när vi skalade om nu har det varit väldigt tydligt att det här är helt rätt för mig.
Entreprenörslivet med snabba svängar, hårt jobb och framfart mer eller mindre.
Så jag tror att det som hör till att vara anställd är att anställningar kommer alltid före eller senare in i en förvaltningsfas.
Och en förvaltningsfas har aldrig varit någonting för mig.
Jag fattar, det känns ju lite så.
Nu kan inte alla träffa det här såklart men det är ju mycket energi.
Värdigt att höra, det här är roligt.
Jag kände när vi började prata.
Jag hoppas att jag ska vidare med någonting.
Min energi är ju alltid typ tre av tio.
Jag är ju alltid aslugn.
Men här känner jag att helvete, jag får stäppa upp lite.
Varför då inte missmatsa helt liksom.
Okej men Omniarts var det första bolaget efter du hade varit anställd?
Mm, så Omniarts var det första.
Du gjorde ingen misslyckad konsultlåda som bara, nej det där var helt fel.
Nej, nej faktiskt inte.
Så jag skulle säga att resa med Omniarts har inte varit spikrak heller.
Vi har ju fått lära oss, vi har ju första gången vi någonsin byggt en konsultlåda.
Kan du berätta lite vad ni gör så att folk får lite kontext på?
Jättegärna.
Omniarts, egentligen hela grunden till Omniarts var egentligen att jag satt på bolag som serverar eller liknande bolag och där jag kände att shit, jätteduktigt bolag, framgångsrikt och vi gör stora förändringar och det går bra, men jag saknade bollplank och jag saknade liknande att jobba med.
Det blev liksom grunden till Omniarts att jag vill jobba med andra fantastiskt duktiga digitala talanger, sitta tillsammans, dela vår kunskap för att tillsammans bli ännu bättre och kunna hjälpa bolag på det sättet istället för att sitta anställd ensam ut på ett bolag.
Så grunden till Omniarts var egentligen inte att bygga en konsultbyrå eller en konsultlåda, utan snarare att bygga en kunskapshubb där vi kunde ta in jätteduktigt folk med erfarenheter från massa olika branscher, massa olika bolag och slå samman den kunskapen så att vi skulle kunna gjort det ännu bättre för nästa bolag vi jobbade med.
Och den contenten av den kunskapshubben blir konsulttimmar med eller mindre.
Så jag brukar sammanfatta det som nu har vi jobbat med hundra olika varumärken.
När vi nu signar vår hundraförsta varumärke så har vi en verktygslåda och kunskap från hundra tidigare som vi kan applicera direkt till det nästa.
Och det gör att vi erbjör att bli väldigt kraftfullt, kompetensen blir väldigt hög, men vi lägger också väldigt mycket tid, energi och pengar på att just jobba med den kunskapsdelningen och sammanfatta det om ni har varit way eller vad man ska kalla det.
Hur sker den här kunskapsdelningen?
För det låter ju som en ganska central del.
Det är en sån där grej som låter fint på papper typ, men man står ganska svårt att faktiskt lösa praktiskt.
Jag vet, jag tror att alla kursuppbolag har väl alltid pratat om det där i alla tider.
Att vi jobbar med någon typ av cross-
funktionell kunskapsdelning, man får fler konsulter, man betalar för och så vidare.
Jag vet inte hur alla andra jobbar, men i vårt fall så stämmer det.
Anledningen till det är att vi har byggt in det från dag ett i vårt DNA och vår kultur.
Så allting handlar om sig.
Den första dagen du börjar oss om Nörs, då får du en bok som heter The Growth Mindset, som handlar om hur du hela tiden ska utvecklas som person och konsult, mer eller mindre.
Sedan fortsätter den här resan.
När det kommer just till kunskapsdelning och den delen så har vi massa olika forum, vi jobbar med utskott och så vidare.
En spännande sak med det är att i början när vi startade bolaget så var det jättelätt att samla alla och prata om någonting och ta del av alls kunskap.
Idag när vi är 50 pers är det inte lika lätt att samla alla, utan vi har fått utveckla hur vi jobbar med kunskapsdelningen, vilket gjort att vi nu kanske jobbar mer med kunskapsdelning inom specifika områden, till specifika grupper i bolaget, till specifika konsulter som jobbar i en speciell bransch eller liknande.
Så det blir mycket mer segmenterat med ännu mindre.
Men framför allt, det viktigaste är så här, det ligger i grunden av vår kultur och DNA att kunskapsdelning är kärnan i bolaget och det är därför vi grundar det omgörandet.
Så det är något vi pratar om typ dagligen med eller mindre på bolaget.
Jag tänkte bara nämna det att vi, till skillnad mot kanske många andra konsultbolag, har ju alltid trott på att grunden i kulturen ligger i så här, får vi våra medarbetare att må bra, får vi våra medarbetare att utvecklas och får vi våra medarbetare att liksom hela tiden lära sig nya saker, då kommer bolaget också att gå bra.
Så alla nyckelkopier i form av finansiella kopier, har alltid varit sekundära för oss.
Vi har alltid fokuserat på att medarbetarna är i centrum, och då kommer allting annat att lösa sig i nästa fas.
Jag tänker många grejer här, men dels måste jag bara säga, fan det är en fin tanke att man tänker på lönsamhet och kopier i andra hand.
Jag ska testa det här i gymkompaniiet, så kraschar vi gym morgon med.
Det är en sån grej som folk som är väldigt lönsamma kan göra.
Vi andra bara önskar att vi kunde göra det.
Skitsamma.
Sen, hur gör ni för att inte, det är ju som när man är i ett klassrum eller liknande, då blir det ju liksom två tre elever som alltid pratar.
Om ni jobbar med kunskapsdelning eller diskuterar eller ni delar i forum, hur gör ni för att inte Baska blir, du som sitter och monologar i fyra timmar och folk bara blir små pellekloner?
Sjukt bra fråga.
Jag har faktiskt fått med att det går om exakt det här, vilket var så jäkla intressant tyckte jag.
Det handlade om social security kallar man det.
Hur skapar man en social säkerhet där alla i rummet vågar komma till taus, oavsett kontext.
Det är svårt att ta 50 konsulter, som dessutom alla är i princip 10-15 års erfarenhet och väldigt seniora, tunga, om en tunga namn, i samma rum och alla ska dela med sig av sina kunskaper eller vad det kan vara.
Därför blir det ett otroligt fokus på att säga social security i form av att alla ska känna sig trygga där.
Men även ifall alla känner sig trygga så är det ändå svårt i sådana formater.
I princip alltid när vi jobbar med kunskapsdelning i större format så jobbar vi med breakout sessions.
Där finns mindre kontexter, mindre grupper.
Där alltid finns någon form av ledare i gruppen som ska se till att alla har kommit i tal.
Så vi stöttar den här delen.
Och sen återigen, jag tror också att det här är så starkt förknippat mot vilken kultur du har i bolaget.
Vi pratar väldigt mycket om, även ifall det inte är det ämne du är bäst på.
Tala ut liksom, fråga.
För det är också ett sätt att lära sig mer.
Även om man inte är ett favoritämne eller ett kunskapsämne det jag är bäst på, så ska jag våga fråga i sådana fall kring.
Och då lär jag mig någonting nytt också.
Och kanske andra också lär sig någonting på det.
Så det handlar både om att dela med sig och att fråga kontinuerligt för att utvecklas.
Hur jobbar man för att...
Jag missförstår mig rätt nu men detta blir ju väldigt fint.
Det blir ju en väldigt utopisk tanke att människor ska kunna sitta och samtala, man ska ställa frågor och man ska få vara nybörjare i sin egen och allt sånt där.
Men er erbjudande måste ju också vara att vara stenhårt bäst annars fyller ju inte allt detta någon funktion liksom.
Så hur jobbar man för att sätta de, vad ska man säga, ja men de väggarna inom vad man får röra sig och när det liksom, absolut nu har du gjort detta men nu är det dags att leverera.
Hur kombinerar man den mixen?
Jag tror det är klart att vara konsult är förväntan att du alltid ska vara bäst eller bidra med mer värde än vad till exempel en anställd gör.
Det är ju jätteviktigt för oss att säkerställa att kvaliteten är det bästa.
Det är i kontext med att i Andersbranschen där vi är framförallt aktiva är väldigt liten i Sverige så levererar vi inte hos våra kunder.
Då har vi inget bolag, så enkelt är det.
Så det är klart att det ligger absolut på våra...
Förutom det här vanliga, vi är utavs-kund, vi har kontinuerliga månadsuppföljningar med kunder, vi har säkerställt att de är nöjda, vi säkerställer resultat och framfart, lägger planer för respektive kunder och så vidare.
Så internt när det kommer till den här delen blir det oftast förknippat med har vi stora kunskapsdelningsforum, då blir det oftast så att vi har flera typer av expertkompetenser inom bolaget.
Det kan vara operationell e-handel, det kan vara djupgående analys eller det kan vara mer emot CRM, marketing automation eller liknande.
Det här innebär ju att de här specialistkompetenserna lär ut av sig varandra.
Vi förväntar oss inte att en generalist ska vara jätteduktig på att göra djupgående analyser kring vad det nu kan vara, CLV-analyser eller whatever, men vi förväntar oss om att den ska vara bäst på sin genre.
Men däremot kan den genom kunskapsdelning också få en grundläggande förståelse för hur optimerar man CLV-världen eller vad det nu kan vara.
Det är någonting som vi hela tiden förspråkar.
Mennes huvudfokus ska ju alltid vara att kunskapsdela, att utöka sin kunskap om sin expertområde.
Det tror jag är grundtanken egentligen.
Men har ni två, jag ska väl kalla dem där, kulturbärare i företaget, en som går runt och är såhär ja det är viktigt att vi pratar med varandra och en som bara går runt och frågar vad fan fakturerar du i förrgår?
Vem är den sura?
Nej, så här.
I bolaget har vi några som värnar extremt mycket om kultur, vilket är jätteviktigt.
Vi jobbar väldigt hårt mot våra medarbetare.
Nöjdhet, vi ska ha flexibilitet, vi ska ha allt det här som krävs för att få ihop livet med en mindre.
Det är egentligen min co-founder Daniel som är väldigt kulturbärare, dels våra chefer i form av team leads eller division leads som hanterar alla anställda och alla fantastiska konsulter.
De här är de som dagligen jobbar med att alla konsulter ska gå bra, vi ska ha rätt förutsättningar för att leverera och så vidare.
Sedan har vi den andra delen i bolaget som är mer resultatfokuserat på vad levererar vi ut hos kunden.
Den blir lite mer, de här måste ju hela ting jobba tillsammans och det här kan vara lite svårt ibland.
Här är kunden, vi måste säkerställa de här resultaten hos den kunden, hur gör vi det?
Exysa och så vidare.
Och de blir mer fokuserade på leverans, hardcore, säkerställa kundnöjdhet.
Och svårigheten med kundsuppbolag är väl egentligen att säkerställa hur får man ihop balansen mellan de här två egentligen.
Jag är också lite intresserad av din roll här, för det var du och några till som startade om ni har ett källor hur det var starten där.
Ja precis, det var tre stycken som grundade.
Det var jag tillsammans med en gammal kollega som heter Mattias, som jag jobbar med i säkert femton år med e-handel.
Typ, typ den duktigaste jag vet på e-handelsutveckling eller i alla fall e-handelsförsäljning.
Fantastiskt, otroligt duktig kille.
Kanske inte liksom en super entreprenör, men liksom jätteduktig på att driva och hålla igång, och säkerställa framfart hos våra kunder med eller mindre.
Och sen var det jag, galna cowboy entreprenören.
Och så var det en kille som heter Daniel, som har varit otroligt viktig om nördsframfart, som egentligen varit ett ansvar i mycket för kultur, byggandet, och hela utveckla omgärdskontexten med eller mindre.
Och Daniel kom från en annan bakgrund, han kom från leverantörssidan, så han har sett hela såhär, vad händer på leverantörernas håll, hur jobbar man med det och så vidare.
Mycket försäljningsbakgrund.
Men för i början var du vd för bolaget, men sen lämnade du över den rollen, här finns det där jättelänge sedan väl.
Ja, jag var vd om ni har varit fram till i våras någon gång, och har varit det sen start med eller mindre.
Men för mig har det aldrig handlat om att vara vd.
Jag tror att det är jätteviktigt för entreprenörer att se den.
För mig, oavsett titel, jag har alltid haft en tes om att nu växer jag med bolaget och en naturlig plats har varit att vara ledare och vd.
Sen har jag alltid trott att jag ska vara där jag levererar mest värde.
Nu har vi växt så kraftigt och vi växer väldigt snabbt också.
Det har varit tydligt för mig att här levererar inte jag lika mycket värde längre.
Det var på grund av att vi hamnade i en väldigt operationell vd-roll, vilket gjorde att tiden var extremt mycket tid till att hantera bara operationella actions mer eller mindre.
Jag ville jobba med affärsutvecklande delar, försäljning och dessutom säkerställa att vi gör ännu bättre resultat för våra kunder.
Det blev grunden till att jag ska nog ha en annan roll.
Sen var vi kallade den rollen I don't care, jag kan kalla den vad som helst.
Det har aldrig varit så mycket för titlar.
Tittar är bara nåt sekundärt för mig att man måste ha någonting.
Sen skiter det inte var det står på papper.
Utan ni är såhär, vad bidrar jag mest till i det här bolaget?
Det var otroligt bra steg och jag uppfattar att vi har lyft om nördskär, absolut nästa kliv i och med det skiftet.
Så det känns jätteroligt.
Var det svårt att inte vara där och pilla?
Eller är det bara skönt att lämna över alla de här tråkiga frågorna?
Det är en sjukt bra fråga.
Jag vet inte, för jag ska vara helt ärlig.
Det är speciellt att vara vd.
Det är fantastiskt att vara vd för ett bolag.
Så jag har haft det extremt krävande och extremt jobbigt emellanåt.
Ja, sen när jag väl lämnade över vd-pinnen då var det väldigt naturligt och jag har inte känt att jag behöver vara inne i det där.
Jag tror på mina kollegor och jag tror att de är till och med mycket bättre än mig på väldigt många saker och det vill jag att de ska få frihet att jobba med.
Man kan ju både hata rollen och tycka om den samtidigt på något sätt.
Det är ju väldigt skönt att kunna ta beslut ganska fort utan att behöva tänka så mycket men det är ju fruktansvärt irriterande att ibland är ju saker bara skit liksom.
Vill man att någon annan ska ta det.
Jag håller med och det som är lite jobbigt ibland med VD-rollen det är ju du som ska ta besluten på gott och ond.
Ja, exakt.
Du pratar lite om att du vill jobba med säljutveckling eller du vill jobba med ja men det verkar ju vara lite mer kreativa delar då men är det det du är duktig på eller är det bara det du tycker är kul?
Vad är du bäst på liksom?
Det tror jag nästan andra får svara på, tänkte jag säga.
Men det jag tycker är kul och det jag tror jag är duktig på och det liksom, om man tänker, nu har vi liksom omnjört och vi har min roll där och det jag tror jag är duktig på i den är att dels liksom att jag byggt upp en rätt stor erfarenhet inom e-handel.
Vi har ändå jobbat med kanske 300 e-handelsbolag och jag har fått insyn i alla dem vilket gjort att jag väldigt snabbt i när jag kommer till ett möte eller en ny kontext kan förstå vilka utmaningar står det här bolaget inför och vad måste de göra för att lyckas med de utmaningarna.
Det tror jag är min styrka inom omnjört idag.
Men det kan ju korrlera antingen till att man har någon form av advisory, att man kan stötta det bolaget i den rejäl personligt jag, eller att man kan bidra till någon form av försäljning, för om ni har ett form av att de här behöver faktiskt hjälp.
Så min styrka och det jag tror jag är duktig på är den delen och sen att jag har skapat ett rätt stort nätverk, vilket gör att jag har fått lärt känna otroligt mycket fantastiska människor, vilket gör att det är enklare för mig att kanske öppna dörrar eller liknande och liksom affärsutveckla på det sättet.
Det tror jag är två huvudpunkterna.
Kan du tycka att det är svårt att särskilja de rollerna?
Jag kan ju uppleva att i trakt med att man lär känna andra e-handlare så blir det ganska naturligt att folk ringer och så ställer man frågor och så sitter man och snackar och bollar någonting.
På något sätt är det ändå ditt jobb att sitta och bolla, men det är också någonting som lite förväntas att man gör gratis.
Det är bara så diskussionen går.
Hur gör du för att dra linjen av att nu sitter jag här som din sorts lossas styrelsemedlem, det här får du betala för.
Hur gör man det på ett snyggt sätt?
Sjukt bra fråga.
Jag har faktiskt aldrig varit i den sitsen.
Om jag ska vara helt ärlig.
Vilket är helt sjukt.
För på något sätt, jag har alltid gått ifrån tese, dela med dig all kunskap du kan, så kommer någon gång komma tillbaka till dig.
Bjud på det du kan.
Jag kommer ihåg en gång när jag pratade med Ella på Smarta Saker, som också är ett bolag som jag sitter i styrelsen på, då hon kontaktade mig och sa såhär, men Gud, vi har fått så sjukt mycket bra grejer från Omniarch nu.
Vad om vi börjar betala er?
Vad hände då liksom?
Det var en inledning på ett långt samarbete med Omniarch, Smarta Saker och sedan som också ledde till att jag gick in i styrelsen där.
Så jag tror inte på att sälja, utan försäljning byggs upp genom att du skapar förtroende, du delar med dig av det du kan och sedan när situationen är rätt och bolaget känner att de faktiskt behöver hjälp, ja men då finns man där.
Och då kan man gå in i det operationellt och stötta och så vidare.
Det är extremt sällan jag har gjort någon form av pitch eller...
Sen tror jag det kommer lite automatiskt, men om man brinner för någonting så blir det lite automatiskt att man automatiskt på något sätt säljer lite grann.
Jag fattar, går du runt och är såhär mjukig god i vardagen också eller har du en hatisk, cynisk sida?
Nej, jag tror det är...
Jag fick faktiskt en fråga om dagen, har du någonsin varit arg eller?
Det kan väl hända att jag kan bli lite frustrerad när jag ska lämna min dotter på förskolan om man måste klä på en eller tio gånger i rad för att de sliter av sig kläderna.
Men jag har nog valt att se livet rätt optimistiskt tror jag.
Ja, det låter jävligt glatt.
Jag gillar mycket av det du gör men jag ser ständigt arg ut och framstår alltid som arg men jag tycker jag är glad på insidan, det bara märks inte utåt.
Om vi tar omgörandet här bara för att fatta det som alltid med konsultbolag tycker jag så är det lite svårt att fatta vad man egentligen gör.
Vi hjälper företag vidare, vad betyder det typ?
Jobba med digital tillväxt, jävlar.
Vad är er grundben eller tre grundben?
Vad är det ni tjänar pengar på?
Super transparent, jag uppskattar det, bra fråga för det första idag.
Vad gör ni egentligen?
Super enkelt och transparent, vi har två produkter eller två tjänster.
En är att vi har en del som vi kallar digital assessment.
Det är typ så här, vad ska den här e-handeln göra nästa kommande 60-12 månader för att lyckas?
Bygga digital tillväxt, tjäna mer pengar och så vidare.
Då går vi in och tittar på allt den där e-handeln jobbar med.
Hur jobbar man med digital marknadsföring?
Vilken organisation har man?
Hur duktig är man på operations och så vidare?
Så kommer en action listare, jobbar man med de här 50 stycken projekten punkterna så kommer ni få fart på det här typ.
Den har vi gjort 150-200 stycken.
Sjukt bra verktyg egentligen, speciellt för nya vd's, det är typ en affärsplan för e-handeln som vi kommer färdiga med.
Det är ett ramverk som vi har byggt och utvecklat under 3-4 år nu.
Jätte lärorikt och bra.
Och många är lite rädda för att jag vill inte ha en strategi, jag vill ha operations, någon måste genomföra, jag vet vad vi behöver göra.
Men den här var ju framgångsrik även i de fallen.
Man får en liten hint om, man får hjälp med hur man ska prioritera allt det här.
Vad ska man göra först?
För min bild är att det finns otroligt mycket duktiga e-handelsbolag uti där, det finns otroligt många som är duktiga på att jobba med e-handel, men det är också så att på något sätt fastnar man in i operations och lägger en sjukt massa tid på saker och gör saker jävligt bra, men man gör helt fel saker.
Då spänner jag tiden på helt nya saker som inte levererar fem spännningar i världen.
Här kommer den här digitala sessmöten in.
Den här tjänar vi inte en spänn på.
Vi snittar 450 spänn i timmen på den, det är typ en affär vi går bak på.
Men det den här bidrar med, det är dels att vi har kunskap om fler bolag, ovärderat för oss, dels att nio av tio kunder väljer att jobba med oss efter.
Det är då vår konsultaffär kickar in.
Här är det då vi går in och driver operations.
Alla våra konsulter kommer ifrån enandes chef roller eller liknande roller, vilket gör att vi har gjort hantverket.
Det är superkonkret det vi går in och gör.
Vi går in och driver affärsutvecklingen och projektet för att utveckla ningen i handen.
Det kan vi alltid från att vi går in och kravställer er Performancebyrås att de blir vassare.
Vi går in och hjälper er med nyckelkopier.
Vi går in och kravställer utvecklingen vid site så att den kommer till era högre.
Eller vad det nu kan vara.
Sätter en säljstrategi, en marknadsföringsstrategi, vi genomför marknadsföringsstrategi.
Väldigt operationellt.
Antingen i form av att vi går in och driver de projekten eller att vi ersätter befintliga resurser.
Du har en e-handelschef idag och den ska sluta eller att den inte levererar.
Då kan man ta in oss och så går vi in och tar rollen och driver den rent operationellt.
Hur länge stannar ni alltid i projektform eller har ni folk som sitter där år efter år och jobbar?
Hur ser det ut?
Jättebra fråga, jag tar MQ som ett exempel.
Där har vi varit deras e-handelsavdelning, vi har ansvarat över hela deras e-handel i snart tre eller fyra år.
Vi ersätter en befintlig avdelning och vi driver den.
Och sen finns det fall då det blir mer projekt kvar, men vanligast är att ett löpande uppdrag, det ersätter befintligt eller går in som stöd för befintligt och sen drivs det under, tids vidare med eller mindre.
Men normal avpasslängd kanske är ett år eller nånting och sen brukar det fort löpa.
Hur gör du för att bibehålla dina konsulter hos dig eller att de fortfarande ska känna sig att de är hos dig samt som kunden ska känna att de är deras?
Det är en lite konstig mix där eller lite svår mix kanske.
Det är sjukt svårt.
För grejen är att alla våra konsulter är väldigt seniora, otroligt duktiga, vilket gör att de får ju, i alla fall gissningsvis, nu vet inte jag säkert, men jag skulle gissa att de på månadsbasis får nya jobböerbjudanden.
Vilket är alltså, okej, hur behåller vi de här 50 supertalangerna då, som hela tiden får nya jobböerbjudanden?
Stenhårda startavtal när ni har tagit ut dem och superkringerat dem, nej det är inte så.
Vad sa du nu?
När de är tokfulla så får ni dem att signera avtal, något sånt.
Exakt så, exakt så.
Det är där grunden i kulturen kom in, för på något sätt har alla våra konsulter, när de är inne i en leverans och har ett intessifte i den, det innebär också att de är en del av två olika kulturer.
De är en del av bolags kultur som de jobbar på, MQ, hemköp eller whatever, och de är en del av omniagekultur.
Där handlar det bara om att vi måste göra det absolut bästa varje dag för att få dem att känna så mycket omniagekultur som möjligt, samtidigt som de måste leverera här borta.
Det blir otroligt viktigt och det är avgörande för oss.
Våra konsulter är värdet i vår affär.
Kan vi inte behålla dem så har vi ingen affär, typ.
Allt vi gör är kunskapsdelning, det är härliga sammankomster, allt det där blir så himla avgörande.
Det måste också finnas en problematik i det kring att växa.
Kan ni bli hur stora som helst innan kulturen lite försvinner?
Jättebra.
Jag tänkte på det här om dagen.
En sak som jag tycker blir så himla bra på omgörd på något sätt, det har blivit så här, att det finns någon form av familjär kultur.
Man frågar, man bryr sig om varandra, inte bara jobbmässigt, utan också privat.
Det är något otroligt fint och något som jag är jättestolt över.
Och det har vi trots att vi idag är runt 50 personer.
Och det är ändå liksom, det är ju några anställda, det är ett gäng liksom.
Och vi är ju också utspridda över landet.
Det är inte så att vi sitter 50 personer i Stockholm, vi finns ju i Åre, vi finns i Stockholm, vi finns i Malmö, Norrköping, Göteborg.
Vi är också den här geografiska utspridningen, vilket gör en ytterligare komplexitet i så här, men hur får vi den här omgörd känslan?
Jag tror att det här familjäran blir något otroligt viktigt i hur vi ser på det och hur vi behåller våra talent.
På något sätt, hela grunden blir ju när de anställda i sig driver kulturen framåt, eller vi behåller det när det är vad man nu vill göra.
Som Daniel brukar säga, kulturen byggs ju underifrån.
Vi kan bara sätta spelreglerna och försöka bygga ett DNA.
Sen måste det utvecklas hela tiden.
Som svar på din fråga, jag tror inte Omniarch kan bli hur stort som helst.
Men det jag tror är att vi är långt ifrån en mättad marknad.
Jag tror att vi kan bli större.
Det jag tror också är att vi bör utveckla bolaget med ytterligare affärsområden.
Typ som vi jobbar på senastiden, att vi har grunden i Omniarch, de är e-handelsjournalister.
Sen har vi adderat analytiker, och adderat CRM och marketing automation, och adderat marketplace-specialister.
Och där kan vi fortsätta att bygga bolaget.
Vad ligger din egna passion?
Ligger den i att driva bolag och se vart ni hamnar?
Eller ligger den i att bygga en viss kultur?
Eller ligger den i att bygga en viss kvalitet?
Asså absolut så kommer du kunna säga, ja jag drivs av alltihopa.
Men vad drivs du egentligen av?
Vad är den stora?
Min stora passion och det jag drivs av är att bygga bolag.
Bygga tillväxt, säkerställa framfart i bolag.
Skulle vi gå in i ett förvaltningsläge, då är jag inte person.
Jag drivs av att vi ska växa, vi ska bli stora, vi ska bli bäst.
Mer eller mindre.
Det är min passion.
Det är likadant när jag går in i styrelse-
eller ägande roller.
Exakt samma sak.
Det är det jag vill göra.
Och sen enablers för att göra det, det är kultur, det är bara bäst med leveransen och så vidare.
Men det har jag drivits av att vi ska vara framfart.
Jag fattar, du ser det andra mer som verktyg, bara att det är jävligt passande verktyg.
Ja, exakt.
Jag brukar säga att jag har gymkompagniet på samma sätt.
Folk brukar säga, är du jättenörd inom gymmetrustning?
Nej det är jag inte men jag är bra på gymmetrustning, jag har varit i den här världen i många år och kontakterna här och allt sånt.
Det är någonting som hjälper mig att bygga bolag.
Det är bara att råka vara någonting jag tycker är intressant, men det är inte det som är huvudgrejen, det är business.
För att byta lite, när ni gör de här, vad var det du kallade de här analyserna som...
Digital assessment kallar vi dem.
När ni gör en sån, finns det några grejer som väldigt ofta sticker ut på ändå yggliga bolag, inte skitbolag, de kanske inte tar in er och inte de allra bästa, de kanske gör sin egna grej.
Men när det ändå är ett bra bolag, finns det några grejer ni ofta upptäcker och bara tänker, fan har ni inte tänkt på detta?
Finns det några riktiga?
Jag vet inte vad Joel, jag ska vara helt ärlig med dig.
Jag blir nästan mörkrädd, när jag kan komma in på en av Sveriges största e-handelsbolag och säga att de inte har koll på någonting.
Det är för mig helt...
Det kan vara bolag som är grundade e-handelsbolag, jag har alltid jobbat med e-handel, men ändå som är så jäkla mycket lågt hängande strukturer som inte är på sin plats.
Det är helt sjukt egentligen.
Och inte för att de är dåliga, snarare att de kanske fokuserar på fel saker.
Eller att man fastnar i operations, och fastnar i fel strukturer och så vidare.
Men om man ska ta några grejer som är väldigt vanliga och ska försöka dra ihop några findings av många bolag.
Det ena är att se över hur man prioriterar sin tid.
Enkelt sagt.
Har man 0,2% försäljning från sitt nyes brev då kanske inte det ska ta halva veckan för en att producera.
Som ett exempel, om man inte har någon strategi kring det.
En annan del kan vara, som vi ser väldigt ofta, mötesstrukturer.
Det är väldigt ofta när vi går in i bolaget och stänger ner hälften av alla möten som sker.
På grund av att det är waste of time.
Det är nollvärdeskapande.
Det kan vara en sån grej.
Och sen, om man ska välja ut en sak där vi särklass ser om jag har historiskt och framåt och levererar absolut högsta värde.
Det är i krav ställande av sina partners.
Alltså digitala marknadsföringsbyråer, utvecklingsbyråer och så vidare.
Väldigt ofta finns det någon bild av att okej nu har vi tagit in en performance marketing byrå.
Nu löser de allt åt oss.
Och så släpper man det.
Men en performance marketing byrå har ju aldrig hela bilden.
De har ingen aning om eran GM3 eller hur ni jobbar med CLV eller whatever.
Det måste man ju bidra med och ge dem den informationen.
Och här är det otroligt många bolag som går fel.
Så där har vi sett att den delen finns det otroligt mycket att utveckla för bolag och kanske förändra bilden av hur man ska jobba med sådana här typ av bolag.
Är det oftast att folk är naiva och inte förstår att man måste kravställa eller är det att man inte vet hur man kravställer eller är det att man inte vet vad man ska kravställa kring?
En blandning av alla tre skulle jag säga.
Folk bara suger på kravställa helt enkelt.
Exakt, exakt.
Lite så, lite så.
Idén är såklart, det är inte alltid som man vill.
Om man ska dra några generella fajner så skulle jag nog säga att det är bland de största och sen lite det här.
I princip alla bolag, inget bolag har en bra uppsatt G4.
Varje assessment vi gör finns det alltid fel och alltid rekommendationer.
Det är också en grej.
Och sen, rätt många bolag har inte heller tillräckligt vass finansiell rapportering, vilket gör att man inte tar rätt affärspessiga beslut.
Jag har ett jättebra exempel, vi jobbar med en kund där man har relativt hög återköpsgrad på sina varor.
Man har en instegsprodukt och sen har man en alternativproduktiv, lite så här Philips shave-konceptet, att man säljer en instegsprodukt och sen måste man köpa raktblad, typ.
I ett sånt case så vill man ju förstå vad av det här är lönsamt egentligen.
Är det att sälja första produkten eller är det att sälja refillsen?
När vi vet det, hur ska vi då anpassa det mot vår marknadsföring?
Ska vi lägga 95% av marknadsföringen på det som är olönsamt eller ska vi lägga det på den andra delen?
Hur ska vi laborera med de här nivåerna?
Väldigt ofta, om man inte har en tillräcklig bra finansiell uppföljning, vet jag att man faktiskt har felaktiga affärsmässiga beslut.
Ja, men fullt rimligt.
För att vi inte ska fastna i det, det är ganska lätt att fortsätta ge exempel i just det där, känner jag.
Man har ju själv gjort ganska många sådana.
Men jag skulle vilja prata lite om, för du är relativt aktiv som delägare eller investerare och sidostyrelse eller du kanske är bara i de bolagen som du har investerat i som du är i styrelsen, jag vet inte hur det ser ut.
Både också, jag har ett gäng, några stycken externa styrelseplatser då jag inte har investerat och sen har jag ibland också en styrelseplats i bolagen som jag bara har investerat i.
Jag börjar lite med styrelsedelen, så får investerardelen bli lite cliffhanger här.
Men när måste man börja ha en styrelse?
Är det så jävla viktigt att ha en styrelse?
Hur fan ska man tänka det?
Jag har ju ingen styrelse, och jag är typ principiellt emot det i bakhuvudet.
Jag kan bara inte...
Ska jag sitta i ett rum med den människor som ska en gång per kvartal bara säga har du tänkt på Finland?
Jag orkat det mer, de är jävla...
Jag älskar det du säger Joel, och jag är så jäkla lika dig.
Det är helt sjukt, jag är ju bolag.
Vad ska jag ha en styrelse till?
Vad är meningen?
Jag håller så jäkla mycket värde i det.
Men på gott...
När man ska ha en styrelse, får svara på den frågan.
Ja, min bild är att du ska ha en styrelse när du vet vad du ska ha den till.
Ja, jag gillar det svaret.
Det är några kontex det jag kommer in i, när jag har gått in i styrelsen, och så sitter jag där på första styrelsemöte och så blir det så här, men jag vill inte sitta här och sitta av tid.
Det är helt värdelöst för mig.
Återkommer i stället, ska jag vara i din styrelse, återkommer, vad vill du ha min hjälp med?
Hur kan jag hjälpa dig?
Om du skulle sätta upp dig i styrelse, i samma fall att du skulle ha ett väldigt bra boldplank för hur du skulle utveckla din affär och du känner att du har ett behov av det.
Då finns det kanske en mening med en styrelse, men att du sätter upp en styrelse som du bara ska rapportera rent finansiellt till, det har du koll på.
Du är ju en grym entreprenör, du har koll på din bolag, det finns ingen som helst anledning.
Så rent sett, när du vet vad du har behov av, då är det dags.
Varför ska man ta in en styrelse istället för att ta in en duktig konsult på just det området som är med under den?
Vad är det för fördel där egentligen?
För mig så är liksom...
Styrelsen har lite andra legala krav såklart.
Men för mig, ifall man tänker rent praktiskt och värdeskapande, så har en styrelse slash advisory board lite samma innebörd.
Och en advisory board är ju en konsult på timbasis-ish, liksom.
Kan man inte bara säga att en advisory board är en billig styr?
Ja men eller typ, jag vet inte.
Advisory board, jag vet inte ifall...
Styrelsen behöver inte vara skitdyrt heller liksom.
Och advisory board kan ju vara rätt dyrt också.
Så jag vet inte, jag tror liksom, ja, kanske förenklat sagt liksom.
Men för mig är det liksom, typsamma sak.
I princip.
I och för att man ser på styrelsen i form av att den ska leverera värde och inte gå igenom finansiella rapporter hela tiden.
Men jag gillar det svaret.
När man vet vad man ska ha styrelsen till, då är det rimligt att ha styrelsen.
Eller kanske personen i den ska man veta vad de ska fylla för funktion helt enkelt.
Det är faktiskt ett av de bättre svarar jag har hört.
Jag gillar det.
Nice.
Om vi pratar om din roll som investerare, hur började det?
Vad drivs då?
Skitsamma, vi börjar med det.
Annars lägger jag upp spänt i fucking frågor.
Jag gillar det här området.
Hur började du som investerare?
Jättebra fråga.
Grunden till att investera har ju på något sätt...
Ska jag säga det så här?
När jag investerar, så investerar jag i princip bara smart money.
Det vill säga att jag kan bidra med värde om jag går in i det bolaget.
Alla investeringar jag har gjort det på.
Det är liksom ett krav för mig.
Jag vill inte investera i någonting där jag inte kan bidra med värde.
Då kan jag lika gärna gå till börsen och köpa någon chansharta laxi eller whatever.
Det är liksom bara ett grundkrav.
Resan börjar med att jag alltid har haft någon tes om att det vore rätt kul att vara involverad i fler bolag.
För mig är mitt investerande ett sätt att lära mig mer.
Jag vill återigen ha lite galen entreprenör cowboy-hatt på.
Jag har haft lite för bred spread på mina investeringar för att jag tycker att det mest vore kul och vi har försökt lära mig en massa olika saker.
Vilket kanske är någonting positivt.
Det har medvarat sig.
Bolag som har kontaktat mig och medelvis har jag tänkt att här tror vi att du kan bidra med värde.
Pelle skulle du vilja gå in som aktieägare och här är en möjlighet för dig att investera i det här bolaget.
Och så har det blivit så.
Och så har det blivit både E&S-bolag och SAS-bolag.
De har fått möjligheten att både bidra och investera i.
Hur luststyrda är de investeringarna?
Det låter som att du går lite på, och du vet såhär, det här låter ball.
Nu låter det ju som att jag bara kör på känsla här, och helt liksom kör free life.
Men på något sätt så är det klart, även om jag till sättet låter väldigt o-strukturerad, så är jag rätt siffrostydig i grunden.
Och det finns några olika faktorer som jag tittar på inför investering.
Det ena är hur ser skalbarheten ut rent nyckelkopiermässigt.
Och sen tittar jag på kulturen i bolaget, otroligt viktig för mig.
Tittar på entreprenörerna, hur är det dem?
Är det liksom en growth mindset hos entreprenören?
Om jag bidrar här kommer den lyssna på den delen.
Så det finns några av de delarna som har varit kärnvärlden egentligen.
Jag gillar den sista punkten, kommer folk lyssna så att annars fyller det inte heller något syfte.
Det finns så jäkla mycket människor som har mycket mer pengar än vad jag har.
Är det bara straight out of pengar, då finns det jättefina riskkapitalbolag som kommer att kunna gå in med mycket mer pengar än vad jag gör.
För min del är att bidra med värde, att jag utvecklas av att göra investeringar, som är kärnvärdena för mig.
Jag tror ofta att man missuppfattas lite för att ta det som du sa där.
Bara för att man pratar lite öppet eller man pratar lite slarvigt.
Men du vet, man pratar luststyrt så uppfattar folk det som att man inte är en siffenörd.
Och jag pratar ju ofta på samma sätt lite som att vi testade här och vi höjde lite där och så där.
Det var någon som skrev på någon så här LinkedIn-grej att ni borde prata med Joel för han verkar mest gå på feeling.
Absolut, det är klart man går på feeling men det är för att jag tror att jag kan säga inköpspriserna på våra topp 250 produkter och vad vi säljer dem för och vad det är för marginal och vad de har sålt för de senaste typ tio åren.
Och därför kan man ju vara avslappnad i det på något sätt.
Och jag upplever att du är lite likadan i detta.
Det var en kollega som sa det någon gång att ta e-handel som ett exempel.
För att lyckas med e-handel så måste du vara lite cowboy.
Och på något sätt när du är tillräckligt trygg i det, det vill säga att jag vet att för att lyckas med din e-handel så måste du testa olika grejer.
Och då kanske du måste bara göra så där, eller göra så där, och du måste testa dig fram, för annars kommer du inte att lyfta din e-handel till nästa steg.
Och då kan man vara mer frispråkig kring det.
Och precis som du säger Joel, det kan ju vara så här, att man uppfattas som, vad vet jag, en clown eller mer frispråkig eller whatever.
Men i slutändan av dagen så är det så här, ja men det är lite av rutinen, erfarenhet och liksom, och sen självklart, som du är som person.
Ja, såklart.
Men det är ju på något sätt som när man är en duktig idrottare till exempel, man lär sig grunde, grunde, grunde under 10, 15, 20 år.
Och man blir bra på bas.
Men ska du bli riktigt duktig, jag är en gammal kampsportare, ska du bli riktigt duktig, då måste det komma en gräns när du gör någonting som inte är by the book.
För annars vet folk exakt vad du ska göra och det blir liksom, du kan bara nå en viss nivå.
Ja.
Exakt.
Så det är först när du kan bli så duktig att du gör 99 procent rätt, att du kan börja experimentera med en procent i taget och veta att du experimenterar med den.
Så att du inte gör det av misstag utan det är faktiskt, det är meningen att göra fel, bara få testa.
Jag skulle vilja hinna med om du har tid att snacka lite grann om personlighetsdrag och rekrytering och liknande.
Ni har ju tagit in ett gäng konsulter och jag har för mig att du har sagt till någon intervju någonstans att ni tar in ganska få av de ansökningar ni har.
Att ni är ganska hårda i det här.
Det hade varit intressant att höra lite vad ni letar efter fördrag hos era konsulter.
Bra fråga.
Kul att du lyssnar in på en annan podcast.
Jag hoppas att jag sa nåt annat, Petter.
Fan, jag har suttit och pluggat det här i två veckor nu.
Jag är ganska nördig när jag gör detta.
Det hade varit skrämmande om du visste hur mycket jag kollade upp det.
Underbart.
Vad roligt du gjorde.
Tack.
När det kommer till rekrytering, jag skulle säga att vi har haft två faser i Omniarch.
Vi kan återkomma till den, men jag kan säkert bidra med lite tips till andra bolag.
Mycket av mina styrelseuppdrag eller investeringar, de delarna har jag också bidragit med hur man kan bygga upp organisationerna.
Så det tycker jag är rätt spännande.
Jag tycker det är lite småroligt.
Men om man tänker på Omniarch specifikt, de började där, så var det egentligen två faser i Omniarch rekryteringsdel.
Första fasen var 0-30 ungefär.
Och det var, återigen nu låter det här lite cowboy, men det var magkänsla.
Typ första 30 person var helt på magkänsla.
Det var en liten nätverk på den delen såklart.
Men det fanns ingen struktur på rekryteringen.
Det det handlade väldigt mycket om för mig var, och det jag alltid har tagit med mig när jag rekryterar människor, det är, hur bra är de på att ge konkreta exempel när jag frågar någonting?
Om du ska liksom driva ner handen eller whatever, du ska bygga tillväxt för nedhanden, vad skulle du göra?
Okej, hur skulle du göra det?
Och de som är duktiga på att ge snabba konkreta exempel, 99 procent av fallen har de varit sjukt bra rekryteringar.
De som är svävande i svar, de som drar ut på svar eller behöver tänka väldigt mycket, väldigt sällan det har varit liksom top notch.
Sen finns det undantag såklart.
Men jag ska inte dra alla under liksom.
Jag tycker att vi kan skita i resten av podden och bara ha det tipset, det är asbra tips.
Det är bara en podd på en minut där du bara säger den meningen.
Så jävla klart fint.
Asnäggs.
Det var första pasen.
Det blev grundet i omnördheten, fantastiskt fint bolag, jättebra sammanhållning.
Vi fick ihop det där oväntat men fruktansvärt bra.
Och sen efter 30 ungefär, så tog vi in en riktig HR, som fick sätta upp en mer etablerad process för hur man ska jobba med rekrytering.
Det är den vi jobbar utifrån idag som är lite mer datastyd, lite mer personlighet.
Vi kollar mycket mer detaljer innan våra rekryteringar idag än vad vi gjorde förut.
Fortsatt i kärnan av att, vi har fortfarande en hel intervju som handlar om praktiska exempel kring e-handeln.
Men innan dess har vi också en fire or higher del för kultur.
Vad kommer den här att passa in i den kulturen vi försöker bygga om nu?
Är det inte det?
Då är det inte rätt.
Det kan vara så enkelt som att vår kultur baseras ju på att dela med sig, vilja lära sig och så vidare.
Vi kan ha Sveriges duktigaste enandes talang, men passar den inte in i den kulturen, då kommer inte vi ta in den i området ändå.
Nu är processen mycket mer, det är tester först, sen är det kulturintervju, känna på den, sen är det kunskapsintervju och efter det får man komma till oss.
Har ni fått bättre hitrate sen ni blev mer avancerade?
Eller var ni bättre när ni gick på magkänsla?
Enkla svaret är väl nej.
Men det är möjliggöra en skalbarhet.
Ja, såklart.
Fler kan det.
Rekryteringsprocessen blir inte upp till mig, utan den blir skalbar så att i princip alla i bolaget skulle kunna jobba med rekrytering.
Så det är möjliggörande.
Skalbarhet, ja.
Särskilt säkerhet, nej.
Ja, jag fattar.
Fair enough.
Du har ju suttit i en del intervjuer och snackat med folk.
Finns det någonting som folk gör när de söker en...
För det är ju lite olika såklart.
Vi har ju till exempel lager.
Jag går ju efter en sorts personlighetsdrag där och så finns det en annan sorts när det är som säljare och sånt där.
Med respekt för att det är olika roller och sånt.
Men finns det någonting som folk gör dåligt på intervjuer som är liksom...
Varför gör folk på det här sättet?
Vad är det de inte...
Vad slutar jag det?
Tycker det förstör dina chanser?
Jag ska dra några exempel.
Jag ska bara tänka en sekund.
Det självklart är det jag nämnde tidigare.
Se till att ha konkreta exempel.
Det är inte viktigt.
Det andra är att oroväckande många har rätt svårt att hålla en röd tråd.
Man blir extremt svävande.
En enkel grej att lösa det kan vara att bara svara på det man frågar efter.
Det kan vara oftast kanske nervositet.
Det hänger lite ihop med konkret också.
Bara ge ett svar på frågan.
Ja men exakt, exakt så.
Det är väl kanske det vanligaste jag har sett som vi kan.
Sen ska jag vara helt ärlig.
Att rekrytera inom e-handel idag, det är svinsvårt.
Det är jättesvårt.
Det finns väldigt många som har lärt sig väldigt bra kring vilka är de populära begreppen, hur ska man prata kring dem, vad är viktigt för ett bolag att jobba mot.
Man kan prata snacket, men i slutändan av dagen så kan den inte det operationella genomförandet.
Det här blir sjukt svårt om du sitter som rekryterande bolag, kanske själv inte har jättebra koll på e-handeln.
Det är väldigt lätt att snacka runt folk idag kring e-handeln.
Här märker jag att väldigt många bolag går lite snett.
Det blir ju kostsamma rekryteringar.
Kan du också uppfatta att e-handeln har utvecklats ganska fort, eller det har gått igenom flera skiften på ganska kort tid och det har varit väldigt starka trender.
Vi hade hela den här dropshipping-grejen som höll på ett tag, hela multi-brand-grejen, det var att man skulle ha open source och sen var det stängt och så var det API.
Folk har hållit på.
Upplever du att folk är lite fast under den perioden då de lärde sig som mest och så har de svårt att släppa det?
Är det ett problem eller är folk generellt sett ganska bra på att bara öppna upp?
Jättebra fråga.
Två perspektiv tänkte jag säga.
En är från rekryterans sida.
Det är oroväckande ofta jag har sett krav på att kunna Magento eller krav på att kunna WordPress.
Skit tillsammans.
Har rätt person jobbat med en annan plattform?
Om man jobbar med en e-handelsplattform så kan man typ alla.
Man lär sig Magento på en timme.
Alltså, whatever.
Sådana skall krav bara sluta med det som anställande bolag.
Det är bara att ta bort det.
Den andra delen, om man tittar på bolag som rekryterar och kandidatsidan, för mig har det varit supertydligt att det finns två typer av kandidater i dag på marknaden.
Den ena är jättestrategiskt.
Då har man suttit på stora bolag, man är som rätt duktig på stakeholders management, man är rätt duktig på att komma till ledningen och säga nu behöver jag 5 miljoner till för vi kan sälja för 15 och vi kommer tjäna 3 miljoner.
Så kan jag få det.
Sen går man ner och delegerar lite och så får det hända lite grann.
Men man kan inte det operationella hantverket.
Man är inte speciellt kanske alltid entreprenör och den delen.
Sen har vi den andra segmentet i den poolen av kandidater som finns.
Då är det den extremt operationella.
Superduktig på operationella.
Jobba SCO, jobba hands on på site, jobba nysprev eller whatever.
Serin duktig på den.
Men kommer aldrig kunna komma till ledningen och säga att nu vill jag ha 3 miljoner till att utveckla vår site för att vi kommer att öka upp konvertering med 2% och då tjäna en miljon.
Den kommer aldrig att hända för den här super operationella.
Det som är det magiska tricket är att försöka hitta kandidaten som är mitt emellan de här två oftast.
Vem är super operationell men kan också stakeholder management och faktiskt förstå att vi kan faktiskt få mer pengar i marknadsföring om vi kan visa att vi kan tjäna en massa pengar på det.
För gör man inte det så kommer man inte att driva sig alldeles framåt heller.
Så där ser jag på landskapet idag kring vilka profiler finns tillgängliga.
Jag brukar kalla det någonstans att man ska kunna prata med vissa personligheter.
Jag är en väldigt specifik personlighet och fruktansvärt dålig på detaljer.
Jag bara säger att vi behöver mer sånt här och så räknar jag med att någon typ ska lösa det.
Det funkar ju bara med en viss typ av människor som inte är rädd för att göra fel och som inte är rädd för att säga emot mig och som har bättre koll än vad jag har.
Det är samma sätt som det du pratar om när man letar utvecklare till exempel.
Den som är huvudutvecklare måste förstå det operationella men han måste kunna prata som en människa, inte prata i två timmar om att tredje raden var ett komma.
Jag fattar inte vad du pratar om, jag bara fattar att du är smart men det betyder inget för mig.
Fruktansvärt irriterande.
Jag skulle vilja avsluta lite med att fråga om, nu är du ju inne i ganska många bolag och du sitter ju i styrelser och sånt där och du jobbar med Omniarch.
Vad är liksom den stora övergripande bilden när du är 84 och du ska gå bort och du tänker tillbaka på det här?
Vad är det du tänker att du ska ha byggt?
Har du tänkt så långt?
Jag ska faktiskt ta inspiration ifrån en kollega som svarade en gång.
Jag tyckte att det var så jäkla häftigt.
Jag ville nästan kopiera det svaret.
Så tar det för vad det är, för att jag kanske inte hittar på det själv.
Men någonstans att se mig när jag blir äldre och driver en massa delar i karriären, det jag ser framöver, det jag skulle vilja, jag ser framför mig att jag sitter på en bänk nere i Spanien någonstans och så kan jag dra den bästa ljugarhistorien vid bänken.
Då har jag liksom lyckats med mina mål.
Jag kan sitta där och dra de här historierna som jag är stolt över och som jag har uppnått med min karriär.
Då kommer jag vara liksom fine.
Då har jag liksom nått det.
Sen liksom hur, för mig är det viktiga inte alltid att säga att vi ska bygga omgörs skitstort eller vi ska göra det.
Man ska vara stolt över det man gör, det är viktigt för mig.
Sen tror jag liksom i min karriär rent konkret så tror jag att jag kommer att fortsätta.
Det är utvecklingsutav, det är ju att fortsätta sitta i styrelser, hjälpa till med den digitala tillväxten.
Fortsätta göra investeringar, det är liksom superkul.
Och såklart fortsätta med mitt operationella jobb inom omgörs.
Jag tror att de tre spåren kommer att vara viktiga för mig från över också att fokusera på.
Känner du någonstans att din hunger ligger?
Man kan ju ibland uppleva att vissa människor, man säger ju så här, unga är väldigt hungriga, eller den här entreprenören är väldigt hungrig.
Upplever du att den fluktererar?
Du har ju fått barn till exempel.
Känner du att den har minskat eller ökat?
Eller känner du att det är något område där du har blivit hungrigare?
Vilken...
Det bara slog mig att den frågan.
Sjukt bra fråga Joel.
Hur upplever du?
Du har också barn.
Ja, absolut.
Jag skulle säga att för mig är livet väldigt konstant.
Jag är antagligen en av de mest jämna människor som existerar.
Jag är nästan...
Min lägsta nivå är jättehög och min högsta nivå är relativt låg.
Jag har bara ett läge och så är det oavsett hur livet ser ut och så har det alltid varit.
På något sätt, ett par gånger när jag har varit tvungen att vara trött och sliten eller när projektet har gått åt helvete eller det har gått jättebra eller folk har kommit och frågat om de ska köpa gymkompaniot.
Jag har tänkt att om jag ska dra mig tillbaka då har jag alltid fått nästan panik och ångest över vad jag skulle göra med mitt liv om jag inte gjorde det jag gör just nu.
För jag älskar det jag gör just nu.
Det spelar inte så stor roll exakt vart det är.
Jag måste bara fortsätta göra det jag gör nu.
För mig är det nästan inte en hunger utan det är mer en såhär...
För mig är det nästan bara som att leva.
Jag har liksom inget alternativ.
Så därför ser jag inte det så mycket som...
Det är många som tänker att om 20 år ska jag göra en exit eller jag ska jobba hårt nu eller jag ska jobba lite nu.
För mig är det inte så.
Jag kan inte tänka mig att göra något annat utan min hunger är väldigt konstant.
Jag bara alltid vill göra samma sak.
Och så bara verktyget i att alltid göra samma sak är att växa.
För annars kommer jag att gå under så jag måste växa för att kunna fortsätta göra det här.
Typ så ser det ut för mig.
Jäkla häftigt egentligen.
Och för mig...
Jag tycker det var jäkla roligt att sitta här med dig i dag Joel.
Det har varit lärorikt för mig också.
Verkligen på alla sätt och vis.
Och ytterligare roligt när vi har lite olika personligheter.
Och skulle jag dra min...
Jag är mer som en rollercoaster.
Mer en berg-och-dal-bana i min...
Jag kan ha en hyfsat mellanlåg lägsta nivå, men min högsta nivå kan vara jävligt hög.
Och då blir det som typ en maskin.
Och när jag når min högsta nivå där jag vill vara rätt ofta, det är när jag själv känner att här bidrar jag verkligen med värde.
Det är det liksom.
Och här utvecklas jag.
Så det finns de två delarna.
Jag behöver hela tiden utvecklas.
Någonting nytt, någonting liksom.
Komma framåt rent personligen.
Och jag bidrar.
Jag känner faktiskt att de här har något nytta av mig.
Det är det enkla svaret.
Jag gillar det och det märks på det bolaget du har byggt och på hur du pratar.
Så det känns jävligt genuint.
Jag håller med dig.
Ett fantastiskt samtal.
Jag är jätteglad att jag fick den här chansen att prata med dig.
Jag hoppas folk har fått med sig några tips och lite inspiration.
Jag håller tummarna för det.
Tack så jättemycket Pelle.
Tack så mycket Joel.
Vi ska sitta i ett rum med fem människor som ska en gång per kvartal bara säga har du tänkt på Finland?